Welcome to AAB Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Welcome to the AAB Testing Podcast, the best podcast in the world that's named
AAB Testing.
I am Spy, or Alan, and I am here with another special guest host, someone who's
been on the show before, sometimes is intelligent, sometimes is just flat out
not. Please welcome Brent Jensen to the podcast.
Woohoo! Thanks for inviting me back.
After that, and speak some more, speak some more, say something.
Something. These are words.
Okay.
Check out the new picks up freaking everything, Mike, folks, everything.
So as long as I stay still.
I just begged for Brent not to play with the cord we were talking, and now he's
doing it just to try and make my blood pressure rise.
As long as I stay still with which Alan, you know, he's asked me before we
started like multiple times.
Okay, are you good?
Are you done messing around?
I'm like, Alan, it's me.
We both know the correct answer to that question on the podcast.
When I told you maybe you weren't here, maybe I mentioned it to one of the
guests, other guests, is I use whisper AI to transcode the transcode.
That's not the right word.
Transcribe every single podcast in the text that we've ever done.
Stop it and then put all that text into notebook LLM.
And now I can go to notebook LLM if I want and ask, in what episode
did Alan yell at Brent about eating?
In what episode did Brent's microphone sound like crap?
And it'll tell me all of them.
Isn't the LLMs great?
Yeah, it's fun.
It's good to see you.
It is summer in Seattle.
It's kind of warm.
It's World Cup.
It's Controversy World Cup.
We're not going to talk about that.
We're not on a sports ball podcast, but it's happening.
So that's what I've been doing.
Watching soccer games, playing some pickleball, getting pretty good.
I'm good enough now.
I think I mentioned this before.
The older retirees I play with, they'll cheat a little bit, and I
let them because it's funny.
And yeah, that's my day.
What have you been up to?
How's it going?
What the hell are we talking about today?
I asked you that just before.
Sorry, that was too hard of a question.
By the way, Brent, this is a podcast.
Oh, I mean, and we're going to pick up right where we left off, like six
years ago, the last time we talked, talking about AI and AI and AI
principles, like something about that.
Yeah, is that where we should start?
No, no, we have to ease into that.
That sounds like that sounds like hard.
Yeah, like I didn't even go back and look at like that would be too much
pre work on air.
I would say let's let's let's ease back into it.
Things are advancing.
The biggest thing in my life, like we did we record.
I don't remember if it's been a month.
So had I changed teams yet?
You had changed teams.
You're on a new team.
Yes.
OK, and I forget.
Are you able to talk about how much the old team sucked right now
or is that for later?
You know, for job security and stuff, we can we can save it.
Yeah.
So so yeah, not great old old team.
It's it's one of the places where once in my career, I was I was
the golden child on the team.
And then I started on the team.
They're like, oh, my God, Brent's going to save the world.
Blah, blah, blah.
And then I started executing against that.
And they're like, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That's not what we wanted.
We wanted you to just do what we fucking said.
And I had a job like that.
It wasn't very fun.
Very rapidly.
The way I described it is right.
But the fall from heaven is much harder than, say, you know, the fall down the stairs.
The team I'm on right now, it was it was absolutely the reverse, right?
The so it was I'm on a team now that I've actually been a partner,
a very close partner with for the last 10 years.
So there's no ignorance.
They they know what I can do and what I do.
Well, they they feel like they really need it.
They're they're happy to have me aboard.
Like in a month, I haven't had so many hugs from people I work with,
like literally in my entire career, right?
They're like, oh, my God, we're so glad that you're here.
We're so glad that you're here.
Been doing a bunch of off sites.
This whole LLM agent, part of part of a huge transition,
because there there's a a reality check that that is pervasive throughout Microsoft.
I'll be honest on that one, but different teams are handling it differently.
And on this team, it's we have to very rapidly adapt
and move in a different direction or we're not going to be here in six to 12 months.
But in this particular case, like other teams,
the way that gets rolled out is more of a adding more fear to the already afraid,
right, which creates self-preservation behaviors,
creates defensiveness and in times of trouble,
people have to band together because it's not it's it's not the world.
Like it's not the case where you can you can run run faster than the other guy.
And the lion will eat that guy.
No, it's no, we're bound together.
If the lion eats any of us, it's eaten all of us because the lion's not internal.
The lion's external lions market forces.
Lion is how the culture is changing.
And this team acknowledges that.
And it's more around, hey, we got a band together as a team.
And that's what's going to be important first, because if we don't nail that,
the rest of it isn't going to happen.
And right.
I'll just say the last org is is like much, much, much more on the opposite side.
Interesting. Yeah, very, very abstract.
Well, we'll leave it there.
I think I think the industry has seen, like even from outside this stage,
I've been gone from Microsoft now for almost 10 years, believe it or not.
Yeah. And you miss you miss.
I mean, those 10 years would have been good.
You would have been proud of those 10 years.
I absolutely believe so. Yeah, I would have died.
But what I see is, yeah, there's been some ups and downs.
And now I hear what my network tells me is it's almost like you don't have to even comment on this.
It's almost like you're not in front as much as Microsoft has been in front,
maybe parts of the org are.
But there's a lot of there's a lot of external forces,
a lot more competition in some areas than you have before that they we don't have to go.
No, no, no. I mean, I'm going I'm going to say it a different way.
Right. So the hyperscalers all face this, whether you talk about Microsoft or Metta or Amazon or GCP,
they're all facing the same sort of thing.
The issue is as companies like, let's say, Anthropic,
who who I think quite honestly, from my point of view,
they are the ones that are staying laser focused on what their mission is.
Right. And that is is is how to enable more of task completion with this tool they've built
and a series of tools that they've built.
Right. Fable is fantastic.
Claude code Claude co-work are fantastic.
And it's it's right.
It's all just tools now.
And the I've been given a lot of speeches lately about Jayvon's paradox.
Are you familiar with that?
Not familiar with and probably none of our three are or one of them are actually whoever that is.
And it's code is a commodity or so I am I'll just say a couple of principles
that I am currently then eventually we get to the paradox.
I will. OK, just checking because you never know.
Valid. There are three key principles that I am living in today,
even though none of them are necessarily true.
But what I find is if I just live as if they are true today,
when they actually become true, I'm going to be more prepared than most.
Number one, there is no such thing as ownership anymore.
Right. You you are if if what would you say is a key differentiator
for Microsoft versus the other hyperscalers?
I don't know. People who refuse to quit, even though they don't know anything anymore.
No, no, no. So market side.
Like businesses, you have all you have all of the big business contracts for all.
OK, enterprise. Sure. And that's what it's called enterprise.
I've been out for a while. I've been playing pickleball.
I forget the words that gets so enterprise.
Certainly there's a lot of people that share that opinion.
And so I am moving forward as if Microsoft no longer owns enterprise. Good.
Right. We have to fight to keep our our position there.
I another one.
So we were just talking about Microsoft. Right.
Many people are going to disagree with me on that one.
And I'm just saying it's fine.
But I choose to live as if that is under attack.
Right. And anything like you can't rely on any moat.
Do you know the definition of a moat?
OK, from for the three, a moat in business language is
is that thing that that protects a key part of your business.
And I'm moving forward with with the idea
that I think is eventually going to be the case
that the only moat that exists is customer trust. Right.
Sure. And we'll come back to that.
I guess I'm just I'm on the edge of my seat waiting for the paradox.
I'm not sure if we're any closer or not.
Fine. The other one I'll say is
there's no such thing as duplication of effort anymore.
That used to be a big philosophy within Microsoft.
But it wasn't it wasn't. But go on.
I'm going to I'm going to. But it doesn't exist anymore.
And the reason why it doesn't exist is because you can't stop it
because disruption is everywhere, because you don't own anything anymore.
So if I have a good idea today, code's a commodity.
I can build if you have a good idea today.
And I go, oh, that's a good idea.
But, you know, you didn't go far enough.
I can build the new thing by tomorrow.
Right. It's it's you.
You don't get to lick the cookie anymore.
And because I can just build a new cookie overnight.
Does that make sense?
It in a sickening way, yes.
I'm still waiting for the paradox.
So the paradox is where my applause sound.
I don't have it. Go on.
All right. So Jayvon's paradox is this phenomenon
where for certain types of goods,
the elimination or the automation
of how we produce that good
actually doesn't end up removing jobs.
It actually creates more jobs in that same space.
So an example of
of this might be coal or electricity.
Like we we we
we figured out how new and wonderful ways
to make it cheaper to produce electricity.
But because electricity is sort of
a basic resource, right?
Now that we have more electricity available,
there are more things that we could do
that previously we had to prioritize.
OK, OK.
One typical example of Jayvon's paradox,
I remember, is like factory workers on a loom,
like they would have a loom and
and the old the old loom and a guy would sit there
and they let's say they could they could loom together
one sheet a day.
And then the next innovation and this part's all true.
The next innovation is they change the design of the loom.
And so that same one person can now do three sheets a day.
Well, back when it was one sheet a day,
really only the rich could afford buying raw fabric
because it was a very limited resource.
But now that the same amount of effort
boosted the productivity,
then they started having a glut of that resource,
which which, you know, in for those who haven't taken economics.
The more you have a supply,
if the demand isn't there, then the supply,
the price of the supply falls,
which then also has a tendency to increase the demand.
Right. And so now you had as we produced
more and more fabric, you had
fabric being exposed to, say, the middle class.
And then factories came along,
massively produced it.
Right. And now you have,
oh, I just need a little bit of fabric because I could now,
you know, patch my clothes or whatever. Right.
The way Jayvon's paradox works is essentially
yeah, it will eliminate, it will eliminate
jobs on the the old way of thinking.
But because the the demand
then goes way up because it's a lot easier to produce these things.
Let me let me clarify understanding.
Yeah, because it's been a windy road.
And so I'm going to draw it straight to AI.
That's what you're talking about here.
The fact that we have today, we have more efficient ships
and we and we've lowered the cost of compute.
So now we run far more compute intensive stuff.
So we still don't have enough commute.
And we're still drawing more energy.
We're still using more water. All those things.
That's the paradox. Is that correct?
That's part of it.
But here, what I was talking about is code code.
So previously, code in order to produce more code,
you needed more people who went through significant training.
Yes, you did. Right.
You need that part.
Makes sense. Keep going.
But now we have.
But now we have the ability to produce code at a whim.
Nearly everybody. Yeah. Right.
Which means things that no one bothered coding before.
There's now going to be a return on that investment.
Yes. And I think you and I have talked about it.
I talk about this all the time.
When I talk about AI, I was talking to a company
where I may or may not work.
And I think I scared one of their test leaders away
when I talked about all of the diagnostic and debugging tools
that we never had a chance to write now become so easy to write.
And I think there's such a open opportunity for that.
I remember working on graphics in early versions of Windows
and spending weeks and weeks writing something
that would allow me to analyze fonts at a minute level
and see where grace killing was happening, things like that.
And those things could get whipped out very I mean,
I should say weeks, months, probably.
And there are there's we both could go back in our career.
There's a large number of decisions I know I made
in the past where I'm like, that's going to take forever.
There's no way testing.
I don't want to use AI for anyone.
Devs, testers, PMs.
I don't care who I don't want people to write more tests with AI.
I want them to write all the tools they never wrote
because they were harder to write than the tests.
I'm fine with them doing both.
OK, they can do both.
It's just as easy because code is just an easily
createable artifact. Right.
It's yeah. Right.
But now what we what where where there's an opportunity.
And I may have shared this before. Right.
Let's let's just agree,
much like the examples that we talked about,
that there is not only a long tail, but a very long tail
of things that could be improved by code
that haven't been because the cost is too high. Yes.
That's all now possible.
That's where that's where opportunity definitely exists.
Right. Agreed.
What do you do with it?
And so what Javon's paradox is essentially saying is because
it's not only because code is a commodity, but what code represents, which is
the software based control of some action or activity,
right, which which if you think if you think of code that way, right,
we have we have far from saturated the market
on using code for that purpose.
Yeah, there's a lot of opportunity.
And so what by bringing the price down, we now open up
the ROI for going after that opportunity. Right.
I think that one creates the need for more builders, not less.
Yeah, it creates the need for more ideas.
For sure. Yes.
And so let me talk about two things in there that I think are important to me.
And actually, I don't even think it creates the need for more ideas
because there's plenty of ideas that already existed that that people have
that that they know because it was too expensive.
Yes and no. And I'll talk about lying in corporate America as well.
A lot of companies and everyone knows this as well.
None of these are secrets.
A lot of companies are laying off people due to AI.
And it's in zero case.
Is it because AI is replacing what people used to do
because there are virtually infinite number of ideas for products
for that within a company with the new companies.
We have not exhausted the idea, the the well of things that could be solved
with software, especially now that the investment side of ROI is so incredibly
cheap to create things.
The layoffs in tech have happened.
Not because in some cases they're trying to save trying to save money
to spend more on data centers.
I don't even think that's it.
I think a lot of companies over hired during the pandemic
and it's a big frickin messy adjustment.
AI has something to do with it.
But I am waiting for there's going to be a rebound at some point
when companies slowly start to figure out what you and I are just talking
about that there are so many things that can make lives easier
for so many people in so many different ways that had never been built
before because it was too hard and it's just not difficult anymore.
That's already happening.
Where Gartner back with extra tricks.
Gartner just did a report on this for several companies and they actually
I'm saying as a consumer looking what's out there, I'm not seeing it.
What what even further so that they're noticing this as a trend.
It's at the beginning of the trend.
But I think at the beginning of the trend doesn't mean it's happening.
It means we both all know it's going to happen.
I'm glad it's starting.
It's not there yet.
Why are you being a dick?
Because it's my job, because you're talking like this has already happened
and it's not.
I will guarantee you at least two of our three listeners are on my team
and say, yeah, of course, this should happen.
Of course, this is inevitable.
But is it happening?
No, I'm going to claim that Gartner claims it is and that they further
predict that by 2027, many of the companies other than hyperscalers,
other than they're not flagging companies like Microsoft, but companies
that bought the bullet and said, we're going to do this, not tech companies,
that they're going to end up hiring back at least 50% of the people
they laid off, which is good.
They absolutely should.
Let me give you an example just to walk from.
And again, this may be happening in fact, it probably is happening
in the tech world already.
So let's have agents analyze our logs and tell us what's going on
versus trying to parse through them.
I'm sure that's much better.
We never had the time to write those.
That's great.
But let me give me and I'll make something up here.
Real estate.
Real estate websites suck.
They're basically shitty.
I don't need to hire like the question I have is a bunch of different things.
A bunch of innovation happened there.
A bunch of things to solve for both buyers and sellers and agents,
all those things, all kinds of problems that could be solved there.
I don't know that software developers need to be solving those problems
because real estate agents who have all the domain knowledge,
given a little bit of coaching on how to prompt cloud code in the right way,
can probably solve those problems for a lot of realtors just as easily.
So do we need to hire them?
What do the developers do in the future?
Because I don't know if they're the best people to be creating code with agents.
I believe very similar to what we've been saying around testers, right?
The purpose of the role will persist.
The tools will change, right?
There is still going to be a need to build scalable systems.
There's still going to be a need to validate customer quality, right?
But the tools will change.
Right.
Similarly, are you saying AI coding tools can't create scalable solutions?
Not today, no.
I bet you there's a Gartner study says there's a trend that says they are.
But you get what I'm saying, right?
That's not a reason that we'll need developers in the long term.
I'm not saying we don't.
I just think that the biggest thing I would say is AI still has a massive cognitive limitation.
There are a bunch of trends that are coming.
There's several of them that I'm absolutely fascinated by.
Like, there is this because the price of the frontier models is surprisingly going up,
not down, it's created a market for these engineers that go,
OK, how can I do local hosting of models using open source models?
And how can I tune the hell out of those or use different techniques to get near frontier
quality or near quality for the tasks that I have at hand?
And I'm like, yeah, go innovators.
Because the thing is, LLM, in my humble opinion, LLM is going to become a commodity itself.
Sure.
Whether it's done because of what I was talking about, an individual in their garage
building, taking an open source model and creating the marketplace for finely tuned
smaller models for specific focus, you don't need a generalized model for all of your tasks.
So what you're saying is it makes sense, and Gartner was there already moving there.
In the long run, move away from the large general models we see today towards the three
or four or 10 we have to a whole crap ton of tuned for specific task models.
Yeah.
I extrapolated and expanded based on what you said.
And I like that idea.
And you're saying that's what developers do is they build new custom LLMs?
I don't know if developers do.
I don't know if I have an answer for this.
I just think that, and maybe one model is.
So that last market is something I think data science moves into?
Sure.
What developers will be freed up, certainly to build up more scalable architecture.
I think and you sound a little bit like you see that cartoon of this is like from 15 years ago.
Can I just say fuck you, Alan, and we just move on, you don't have to figure out your metaphor.
It works at web scale.
Yes, I hear you say scalable.
So maybe a hybrid of that is in the short term.
Because I think you just need the only thing you need to build scalable software
from what LLMs do is a tuned LLM that works on building scalable software.
That could be someone could go solve that soon.
But in the short term, maybe what happens is I really like the idea of domain experts
creating much more of the software like here's I want real estate to come to the ID
department and go like, OK, here's we created this thing.
Can you make it deployable to our whole fleet?
And then maybe that's what the devs do.
But I don't know how can I don't know that a dev can prompt something outside
of their domain expertise better than that person that domain can.
So my prediction is I think those domain experts are creating a whole crap ton more
of the code than they are today.
They are.
Yes, I know they are.
It's going to happen.
There's going to be more.
There's but there's still a role.
Like, let me give you a very concrete example that that even with the current
models, I'm not certain is fixed.
This this this happened in my last team a couple of months ago.
I had used LLM.
I had built a really sweet like.
I could care less about Power BI anymore, right?
I'm a data scientist.
I do a lot of presentations, OK, but building the Power BI because of the
DAX language is DAX is very complex.
They don't have copilot integrated into that, in my view, the correct way.
And it's just as easy for me to tell asked my my buddy GitHub copilot, hey,
now that we've done this, can you build a dashboard?
Right.
Just as easy or it's even easier than than diving into Power BI.
So I did.
I had a sweet dashboard running, bringing in signals near real time.
Very responsive.
And then so this I see basically a couple of years into our new career
hasn't done anything with with data science or with development, no training
in development at all, and all of her training on data science she actually
did in my team.
And I said, I'd like you to take this over and I want you to extend it
this way.
OK, and she did.
And she's like, hey, Brent, I want to show you I did it.
I integrated.
I added these new things.
And I looked at it.
Absolutely.
She showed that she had achieved the what I had asked her to do.
But the whole app was sluggish AF.
And I'm like, I feel like without you really noticing it that the LLM
added this job to the main thread.
Right.
So we've heard the story.
What's the main thread?
Exactly.
And this is a place where where LLMs still are at a point where they give you
what you ask for, not necessarily what you need.
And so you're still as a as a builder sitting down, you're still limited by
knowing what you know.
And this is yes.
And I want to build on that because the challenges if you and I is the
same thing, your other employees, a great example, if three developers are
all given the task of implementing something, the way you prompt, the way
you give context through the chat interface, the LLM, we will get three
different solutions, 100 percent true, which is and again, the real
estate person, they're not going to go with the main thread is.
But they're and so, yeah, that there's some architectural things they
won't know.
But the LLM can be taught to take care of those over time.
But the ability, the critical thinking, the judgment, the creativity, I
absolutely abhor the term prompt engineering.
But I will say that everyone creating code would not necessarily
developer, everyone creating code needs to be able to need to prompt in a
way that gets answers.
Actually, I'm going to back it up from code.
There is like there are ways to prompt an LLM about anything that will give
you better answers or worst answers.
And I want to take us all the way back away from computer software.
Who gives a crap about that?
Just like let's talk about schools or education.
Don't tell kids to avoid A.I.
It's not going away.
Teach them how to use it.
Teach them how to ask your ask questions.
Help them learn how it works by prompting it in different ways.
Understanding what comes out.
I am of a mixed emotion on that one, but there are so many and this is
the same like people would come to me years ago and have me search
for, they'd say, I can't figure out how to do blah, blah, blah.
I said, just search the internet.
I said, yeah, I said, why are you coming to me?
It's because you search better than I do.
And yeah, and it's that times 10 with chat interfaces to LLM.
When it comes to have to be careful when it comes to kids and when
it comes to education, OK, there is a there is a trend that I find
disturbing and and I think educators I'm going to do my part to think
through this, but I think educators have not struck the right balance
around teaching it the tool as a tool because the teachers don't know.
No, and that might be it.
But let, so let me explain the problem.
Um, there's a growing trend where students are not learning shit
except for how to get the LLM to give the answer.
Yeah.
Well, that's just poor teaching.
It's not poor teaching.
Yes, it is.
It it's poor testing.
It's not teaching at all.
I disagree.
It's the one.
One example I read about just a couple of weeks ago was around.
There was a group project.
It was, it was written up by one of the members of the group in, and she
knew the majority of the other groups of her, of her own group.
We're using LLM to produce slides.
So they had, it was a debate class and they had to, the, the
teacher split the class into this side supports this side refutes.
Okay.
And this was a college level class and this person was writing
out and said the majority of the other slides that came out of
my team, they produce the slides and they were able to talk through
them, but they didn't understand them even to the point of not failing
to understand that they were arguing for the wrong side, right?
And so, so I am absolutely concerned about the construction
of intellectual laziness.
It's, it's, this is why teaching, this is what I'm talking about.
This is why the answers are so easy, just like codes easier
to create than ever before.
The answers are easier to find than ever before.
You, we need to teach critical thinking and judgment and evaluation
and those skills, those help with using LLMs, those help understand
those things, those things aren't happening and using chat interfaces
on LLMs, it is a fantastic opportunity to teach those things, but the
teachers don't know how to take advantage of that either.
I'm going to take it further and I don't even care if it's
the teachers that do it.
This is something that I've talked with all of my kids.
We'll pretend you're one of my children.
Alan, what is the job of a teacher?
And the easiest answer to give is to teach.
Correct.
And it's an incomplete answer at best.
It's not only incomplete, it's fucking wrong.
Okay.
The job of a teacher is to get their students to learn.
I don't need, I don't care if you teach it, but your job isn't to teach.
You, you, you, if you gave up, went up there and gave a brilliant
presentation and none of your students learned anything, you may as a
teacher go, well, I taught, they're just morons.
Yeah.
And I'm like, no, that is not your job.
I, while I agree with what you're saying, it is a little
semantic because they're just not teaching in that case.
They're just talking.
Anyway, go on.
That, that, no, to me, that, that, that is not semantic.
It's actually the, the single most important thing.
It's the same thing to me.
Like, what is a leader?
How do I know if you're a leader?
Well, because you have, because you have followers.
You, you cannot be reorg into leadership.
Well, and there's, and there's, this has been a much better podcast.
We just talked about the difference.
Like just because you're a teacher doesn't mean you get your students to learn.
Just because you're a leader doesn't mean you have followers.
You, those are both things you need to develop and earn with
your team or your students.
Teacher.
Can we start over and talk about that?
I got, well, no, I'm supposed to take my daughter to an errand.
I'm like, I got nothing else better to do.
Let's get to the part of the podcast.
What's like, what's the takeaway?
What's the point of this discussion today?
What, what did we accomplish in this slight debate discussion around AI?
I believe, I absolutely believe I sufficiently covered J van's paradox.
That was in there.
Yeah.
I, um, uh, I, I showed that my new microphone is awesome.
And if you're listening right now, wonder why his voice sounds
better is because it's actually within a foot of the microphone
versus sitting back in his chair.
It was noticeable.
Oh yeah.
It's much better than last time.
People are, there will be, there will be positive comments about
your microphone.
This is what I've created.
I've created Brent sitting back and leaning forward in his chair,
doing a, doing a part of a Gregorian chant.
I've got, I've got a preview next episode where we have a little
bit more, uh, sensible topics in order, but like, what do you
want people to take away from this?
Javon's paradox.
What's happening with AI?
Uh, lots of things.
The thing, the thing, the thing I think that's important
and feeds into what I, but I hope will become, you know, the
modern, the post-modern testing principles, whatever the hell we
name it, but it's very similar to when QA started to disappear.
Yeah.
Right.
It's no, you, you, you got to head, you got to understand
what has actually been done and, and make the, make the
changes that are necessary.
Right.
It in, in back then it was testing as a tool for assuring quality.
It is better suited under dev.
Right.
But quality, if your identity is around, my purpose is to
deliver quality and like Alan and I, we, we, you, you, you
agree that quality is defined by the customer, not by you.
It's not craftsmanship.
It's utility, right?
Where we're in the same sort of transition, like the, the, the,
we're just changing the tool set.
Yes.
And I, and I'm a big believer.
You hear me talking about this or write about it, at
least quality as a system is produced by the system, which
is everything, including not just what the agents and the
people are doing, but what's rewarded, what's incentivized,
what, what all the little things that make up the system of
delivering software and that system is changing a lot.
So when you change one part of the system, you have to be
aware of what it's doing to the other parts.
And that's going to be something else good for us to
talk about as we get into whatever postmodern testing is.
Absolutely.
Now look forward to that.
So are we on a regular schedule now?
Do we talk every two weeks?
Yeah.
So we, we are back on the regular podcast thing.
Uh, I still have some, I might, I might, I can't decide
if I want to subject guests to Brent or not, we're doing
on my own, but, uh, we might get some of those in there too,
but I am excited to talk about things are changing.
I honestly don't care.
I know you don't.
Yeah.
And you be you boo.
Maybe to recap, when we first started this podcast, it
was because testers saw agile happening and didn't know what
the hell they were supposed to do.
And we saw a path and we saw a path and a pattern that
was happening industry-wide.
We began talking about that and expanded on that.
And the first time I talked about this 10 years ago at a test
conference, uh, I thought I was going to get booed off stage,
but I, I did not.
And people come up to me and said, thank you for giving
a name to what we've been doing.
So it wasn't what we're, we're not trying to tell,
describe some new way we're inventing.
We're trying to describe what's actually happening.
And I think what we'd like to, what we're moving into,
if I understand, and I brought to think we're on the same page
on this is we're going AI, shit's changing even faster.
We'd like to talk about how teams, not just testers, teams.
That wouldn't see not even just the engineering teams.
I would say how organizations adapt to how the world is
changing with AI and I can bring the quality of the
system part to it.
And you can bring the knowledge about AI that I will
make fun of part to it.
And we may get somewhere that's kind of exciting.
Call it the AI testing con what's your middle name?
Start with an I no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe you can legally change your name, but we may need
to be the AI testing podcast, but just something, just
a random idea there.
The, uh, a board, right?
I, for the software industry, like, I think this is, this
is my view.
I think this is our last major shift and what comes
after that is going to just be continuous path changes
from here on out.
Like once, once, once the engineers and participants
since in, in software make this shift, then it's, it's
just going to be a continuous shift if it's not
already there.
It'll be a fun ride.
Get on the roller coaster.
Woo.
Yeah.
Wait, get on the roller coaster.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I forget the movie, but there was a movie where
this, this grandmotherly lady talks about, there
are two kinds of people.
Those who like the roller coaster and those who
like the merry-go-round right in, in the merry-go-round
is nice and safe and comfortable, but the
roller coaster is exciting.
I don't, I, I'm so bored on the merry-go-round.
I think software industry, like if you're a merry-go-round
person, it's, so you want to be, you're in for
a lot of anxiety going forward.
I think.
All right.
I think it's important to adapt and we adaptation
is more important than we've been.
So is a bunch of other things.
We're, we're kind of out of time.
We've got to go like, um, do you have more
wiring to do in Satya's house?
Did you have the GPUs installed?
No.
I'll go with, okay.
Well, you might get a bread has to head back over to
Satya's install GPUs in the attic.
It's for a big lighting thing.
He's doing for Christmas.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
Um, but it's good to see you again.
And, uh, I am Alan or spy.
And I'm great.